[Musique]
à
salut
les terriens
notre invité ce soir c'est le mec de
brefs
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
alors votre vrai nom c'est yann khojandi
nous on va garder de mettre de brefs
vous savez comment vous appelez très
longtemps le mec de brefs qui est assez
paradoxal finalement c'est vrai en p2
nous accueillerons laurent wauquiez
laurent wauquiez qui soutient françois
fillon dans la course pour la présidence
de l'ump comme beaucoup d'anciens
ministres sauf rachida dati qui soutient
christian louboutin
toujours en p2 nous accueillerons eric
naulleau eric dupuy une compilation de
ces critiques depuis 20 ans nous dira
comment il a fini par succomber lui
aussi au charme des livres qu'on écrit
avec une agrafeuse
enfin en p3 après le zapping et gaspard
proust nous accueillerons notre invité
du samedi 20 heures ce soir aurore
renault
il se bat pour la reconnaissance du
droit des mamans lesbiennes
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens et le monde
yann re bonsoir mon sort alors début
2011 vous êtes dans une période de
grosse remise en question de galère vous
payer votre loyer à coups de stand-up et
de rsa vous avez envie de baisser les
bras qui a dévoyé pas très bien ce qu'on
pouvait faire de toute façon exactement
ouais je suis comédien je sais faire que
ça dans ma vie est hors de question sur
la chose et c'est là qu'en préparant
votre nouveau spectacle j'avais l'idée
de raconter des tranches de vie d'un
loser en gros oued un mec normal sur moi
raconte est super rapide ouais ça rend
ce avant la loose un peu un peu moins
évidente voilà alors vous dites à
l'image de la série tout s'est fait très
rapidement
début avril notre producteur présente
l'idée à canal bon qu et ont filmé les
quarante épisodes en août c'est
rarissime ouais ouais on a tout fait en
un jour on a fait rentrer 30 jours de
travail en vain
ah si vous fait alors le pitch est
simple au début on est à la fin on meurt
entre les deux il se passe des trucs
bref c'est l'histoire d'un mec entre les
deux
alors vous êtes ici ce soir pour la
sortie du double dvd l'intégrale de la
série bref du dvd blu ray intégrale du
livre et du coffret collector avec le
double dvd des bonus et une clé usb avec
la bande originale de la série
bref vous venez pas les mains vides
break bien bossé là dessus alors on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
c'est
bref un jour j'ai eu 30 ans tout le
monde m'a répété
je crois qu'ils n'ont pas tort à ce que
j'ai un pote qui a eu un enfant vote qui
est devenue médecin un pote qui est
parti du jour au lendemain dans un pays
étranger j'ai eu quatre pannes sexuelles
a exactement je me suis demandé ce que
je voulais faire de ma vie je dis non je
me vois pas me coucher tard à des potes
je rentrais chez moi j'ai pris un bain
et en plus j'ai mis davoust j'ai dit à
quelqu'un me dit ça maintenant tu me
tues verra plus tard quand je vais aux
toilettes où l'attend un deux trois
quatre secondes avant de pouvoir fils et
mes potes me parle de crédit d'impôt ou
de retraite quand je joue avec mes
transformés en centres de vente il fut
un collectionneur one more time des daft
punk à 11 ans jurassic park ave 19 ans
les simpson ont 23 en hiver je prends
des vitamines j'ai déjà marcher près de
la mer avec un pull autour du cou kg et
messages edi best sont à quelqu'un qui
écoutait de la musique crédit et
souffler dans une rue qui monte j'ai
entendu des jeunes parler entre eux
j'ai rien compris je me suis rendu
compte que je les appelle des jeunes un
dimanche j'ai brunch et j'ai pris un
taxi parce que j'avais la flemme de
prendre métro j'ai trouvé qu'un jeu
vidéo allait trop vite j'ai acheté une
théière j'ai une marque de thé préfet ne
suis pas assez jeune pour la carte 12-25
et pas assez vu pour la carte senior
j'ai acheté des boîtes oranges et je
mélange plus les couleurs quand je fais
une machine mais je comprends les
tickets de mes pulls je suis déjà parti
en vacances pour me reposer et j'ai
utilisé le mot art n'a plus bougé restée
allumée j'hésitais à la souffler qu iron
l'attend
bref j'ai eu 30 ans
découverte autour du vin votre forfait
pour le nos logis depuis le temps je dis
qu'il faut qu'on le fasse a préféré
aller je fais la bise à tout le monde
soit
[Applaudissements]
dans le double dvd avec 82 82 à 89
vraiment vous voudrez mais c'est un
boulot de chien parce que certains
numéros il ya 140 planque huawei 140
coupe de plan mais il ya on a fait un
record c'était trois heures sur deux
secondes ah oui alors voilà donc en une
saison vous êtes devenu culte ça fait
quoi d'être culte au quotidien il paraît
que les gens arrivent à écrire votre nom
de famille sans faire de fautes
d'orthographe il gagne au scrabble avec
le gas oil rich laurent wauquiez au site
s'appelle combat de scrabble aujourd'hui
alors vous devez une rock-star vous
faites le grand rex
rassurez moi c'est pas de vous dont
parle christophe hondelatte quand il
chante j'aime le cuir et latex et les
toilettes du grand avec son cerveau il
chaud en date
[Rires]
alors bref a inspiré de nombreuses
parodies en plus chez nous un style bref
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
ce mec mal réveillé la dans son lit
c'est moi dans la vie avant ma vie elle
était normal et puis laisser thierry sur
canal
un matin j'ai reçu une vidéo sur
facebook c'est un épisode de bref avec
écrit matt samecki at-on sosie je vais
sur le site et la direccte j'hallucine
ce mec c'est vraiment mon sosie
[Musique]
bref aujourd'hui je travaille dur le
téléphone sonne je fais semblant de ne
pas entendre il continue de sonner je
tourne la tête il sommes encore
j'exprime mon mécontentement
dans la rue on a croisé mélissa theuriau
parce que c'est ma voisine
[Musique]
bonne journée j'ai regardé partir j'ai
compris que c'était pas mal in que je
devais trouver mais la sienne j'avais
pas kleenex gipa kleenex
j'avais pataca
kg bon c'est l'expression vie mais
combien de balles seront chargés par
être at-elle le cap et les casquettes en
plastique mais pourquoi pourquoi
trouveront ils la portent la clé
d'accord la poignée de porte se
lancera-t-il dans la bd l'alcool la
coiffure arrêtera-t-il de la regarder
une fois trois fois dix fois ça va
[Musique]
c'est un des gars comme ça aussi
rapidement bravo merci vous vraiment
bravo et merci bien même il ya même un
préservatif bref way olivier geay
accusateurs preco
voilà et puis alors à la fin de la
première saison vous arrêter
ceci étant une cei qui s'appelle bref et
qui dure dix ans c'était pas très
cohérent finalement way et
personnellement je kiffais prison break
la saison 1 ouais et la saison 2
philippe en effet un présage
alors on passe maintenant à l'interview
portrait
[Musique]
et
alors qu'ils aiment qu'aujourd'hui dans
la vie au début on naît vous souhaitez
le 29 août 1982 à reims vous êtes
d'origine iranienne comme la prochaine
guerre mondiale
alors en iran votre père était géologue
il est parti à l'arrivée de l'ayatollah
khomeini il s'est reconverti en france
dans le commerce de tapis
c'était dur pour lui de changer comme ça
de la situation ben c'est pas facile un
plus c'est ccc reste est vachement dans
la famille le fait de se dire les gars
ouais encore partir à jour plusieurs
élans sa vie mais en tant que marque
l'arrivée en même temps éléments votre
père venu c'est un gros rat conteur de
blagues voulez mais beaucoup hein
normalement oui alors votre maire et
picardes
fille d'une femme de ménage très
mélomane elle aurait voulu être
chanteuse ou comédienne mais voilà elle
est devenue juriste dans un cabinet de
formation alors déjà les en iran un oui
une fois et je me dis mais tu es fou
s'il m'était complètement cinglé je dis
ouais je sais mais je faut que j'y aille
mais non c'était c'était normal en fait
c'est juste que bombe à la balle la vie
est un peu bloquée dans les années 80
donc le parc automobile est un peu vieux
mais j'ai jamais vu des gens aussi
libres dans leur tête c'est très évolués
contrairement à l'image qu'on exactement
énième fois qu'il ya une vraie mauvaise
image mais j'étais allé une fois mais en
revanche quand vous étiez chez vos
parents la famille d'iran vous visiter
souvent harmonie tout le monde mangeait
par terre et rester dormir là y'avait
toujours 15 personnes à la maison et des
matelas par tout ça c'est vrai ça j'ai
grandi avec des matelas sur les murs et
quant aux familles arrivées up
donc bah ouais ma grand mère venait six
6 mois par an dormir à la maison et
qu'après leur partie en iran j'ai grandi
et que cette double culture en
permanence et la culture américaine en
plus dans la télé donc ça fait street et
rock and roll votre grand mère ouais
mais elle avait divorcé en iran dans les
années 50 ce qui est rare ici c'est une
âme que j'aime énormément vous parlez
persans vo pris dix mois un truc en
versant thierry je suis très content
d'être avec vous thierry martin hirsch
obame tous à lui est à l'agonie ohlala
[Applaudissements]
alors le reste de votre vie est beaucoup
moins exotique vous passez les 23
premières années de votre vie à vous
ennuyer dans un quartier pavillonnaire
rémois mais un ennui formateur vous êtes
dit si je veux pas crever là il faut que
je me bouge c'est pas ça c'est que
j'avais un parcours classique lycée bac
études de droit ont maîtrisé je suis pas
j'ai un peu mal au dos en fait à chaque
fois tous les matins j'ai un peu mal au
dos et puis bah je sens qu'il ya un truc
qui colle pas et je kiffe faire des
petits films avec mes potes des films
légaux ouais super pote ya quinze ans je
prends ma première caméra et je fais mes
petits sketches à la manière des
inconnus des nuls et puis je sens que je
sens qu'il ya autre chose d'ailleurs en
fait et puis à la musique à 6 ans vous
entré au conservatoire musicales de
reims vous apprenez le violon alto
pendant 12 ans et vous avez l'oreille
absolue c'est à dire que vous pouvez
reconnaître n'importe quelle note comme
ça à l'oreille oui je peux essayer en
tout cas est-ce qu'on peut essayer
c'est un dos il ya eu 1 me en sierre r
ouais
alors
les rangs la question qu'on se pose
c'est une oreille absolue est ce que ça
se nettoie avec un coton-tige
donc après le bac vous intégrez la fac
de droit de reims
et les premiers jours un ami vous parle
du cours simon cours de théâtre à paris
vous y allez et c'est une révélation
j'apprends qu'on peut apprendre le
métier d'acteur en fait ouais c'est pas
que pour les maisons dans la télé ouais
c'est pas que pour les gens dans les
films et
et j'essaye en fait et je rentre dans ce
court et
j'assiste à un vrai changement s'il ya
des c'est rare dans la vie c'est pour ça
mais à une seule fois j'étais assis sur
un banc qui fait vraiment mal au cul
pour et tu dis ouah je veux tous les
matins de ma vie ce soit ça ouais et je
suis jamais revenue en fait voilà alors
à paris c'est pas facile pour autant
parce que pour payer les cours de
théâtre et la coloc parce que 12 mètres
carrés vous bossez à l'accueil dans une
banque d'affaires ouais je sais là
bonjour bien de travail
je me dis waouh si j'arrive à faire rire
des gens qui n'attendent rien de moi à
7h20 du matin je crois que je
et puis voilà après vous commencez à
faire des scènes et vous avez à new york
fait du stand up à new york c'est
incroyable c'est gonflé quand même bah
j'avais envié je me suis dit en fait il
y avait il y avait des scènes un peu
anglaise à paris et je commence à monter
à et le ballet mal à meskiana et two way
iranienne ton de biscayne c'est rare au
général des américains ils ont peur d
irène roulage à lépanges en tant
qu'iranien j'attends qu'on française est
encore plus marrant quand tu dis bonjour
je suis français est marrant et ils sont
morts de rire
après vous faites des télés quoi
commencer à bosser un petit peu la télé
fait clients cadres d'être
jusqu'au jour où vous inventez bref et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui si vous refusiez
bref ça serai bref j'ai reçu un chèque
de 3 millions de la csn
bref je baise avec qui je veux bref j'ai
dit non à la deuxième saison sur canal
c'est vrai
si j'avais voulu de l'argent j'aurais
fait une saison 2 voilà voilà vous
n'êtes plus malin que ça ouais ouais
l'article le longe artistique il était
plus important vous avez s'attirant 80
deux épisodes on va pas aller plus loin
et voient pas surfer sur un truc et
peut-être qu'on fera un film web à
essayer en tout cas
[Musique]
- bonsoir luthérienne rebond sur le
terrain
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
cannes khojandi
alors ok
eric naulleau
laurent wauquiez bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes député ump de haute-loire
réélu avec 63% des voix alors que l'on
avait fait 50 % vous êtes maire du
puy-en-velay où vous avez récemment
interdit le déroulement d'une combi ou
qu alors une zombie walk c'est des gens
qui s'habille qui se maquille en zombies
pour défiler dans les rues alors est-ce
que le clip de michael jackson fuient
leur est interdit aussi au puy-en-velay
en fait en fait la réalité c'est que
j'ai été traumatisé dans mon enfance par
ce clip ouais et donc comme maire je
voulais paraît avoir des zombies dans ma
vie ouais d'accord voilà en plus
simplement c'était là tout ça et vous
êtes des c'était une association qui
nous a déposé sa demande trois semaines
avant on les connaissait pas bien on
s'est dit bon on va attendre et break
qu'est ce qu'ils font alors ça veut dire
un coup puis on veut les regarde et on
peut se balader comme ça et on peut pas
se balader comme ça voilà c'est comme ça
quand je vois les deux photos je
comprends maintenant
il faut comprendre que les hommes
politiques préfèrent les morts qu'ils
votent plutôt que les mortes mars les
séparent nous aura beau jour aux époux
tiberi était de nouveau dans l'actualité
cette semaine alors comment ça se passe
la vie d'ex ministres parce qu'on a eus
rachida dati qui nous a confirmé qu'elle
s'est acheté un sac rouge bruno le maire
qui nous a raconté qu'il avait beaucoup
écouté de musique classique et vous
foutez quad vos journées 1 c'est moi
j'ai ressorti mon vélo avait cédé alors
nettement ça fait plutôt du bien quand
même c'est enfin on reprend un peu de
liberté on n'a pas systématiquement
quelqu'un à côté de vous vous avez vu
sarkozy sur le dos surtout
j'ai regardé ça vous fait pas drôle
depuis tous les soirs au grand journal
alors là maintenant rigole plus demain
c'est les élections pour la présidence
de l'ump alors vous vous n'êtes pas
copéiste dans l'écho pays c'est ce
qu'ils sont anti musulman vous vous êtes
fillonniste et vous êtes anti zombies
dit mais c'est au fond pas totalement
faux seins ouais c'est à dire que dans
le discours de copé il ya quoi il ya 80%
du discours qui est sur l'immigration
ouais françois fillon lui il est plutôt
sur les questions d'emploi de pouvoir
d'achat mais chez copé c'est un discours
qui consiste à dire la politique c'est
clivé chez françois fillon la logique
c'est la politique c'est rassembler
ouais donc d'une certaine manière j'aime
bien cela c'est une bonne analyse les
anti musulmans votre maison du zombie
alors si j'ai deux filles on vous dit
dans le figaro attention malgré ses
pépins de santé il n'a jamais baissé les
bras sans aucun moyen du parti portée
par l'élan des bénévoles il a mené son
tour de france mais c'est un sens c'est
un héros alors sérieusement même un
simple il s'est fracturé la jambe ouais
il s'est pris une colique néphrétique
loué il s'est pris des calculs oui moi
je les retrouvais aux urgences à
montluçon la semaine dernière c'est un
mec à la scoumoune à maturité je suis
raide ou je ne sais pas comme président
quelqu'un qui sait qui c'est reparti
ouais j'ai tendance à penser qu'un bon
capitaine c'est pas celui qui a pas
d'épreuve celui qui ont cela dit les
épaves allant au sujet de copé vous
dites alors là avec copé c'est marche ou
crève il nous a mis un jour un pistolet
sur la tempe en nous disant sois tu es
avec moi soit je te coule dans le béton
il a vraiment dit ça ça nous étonne
beaucoup venant de cope with protéger
les sympathiques ouais je suis très
surpris on parle bien de copé le mec a
fait sciences po etc roumanoff
celui que vous habitiez à votre table et
qui avait l'air très polis mais non
sincèrement indépendamment de sa c'est
vrai que chez jean-françois il ya plutôt
une gestion un petit peu que l'on
sincèrement il faudrait répondre à la
question c'est ce que c'est faux c'est
par sincèrement que des risques il a
vraiment prononcé cette phrase
je maintiens ce que j'ai dit
vous êtes pour kivu entre fillon et copé
est-ce qu'il a d'abord sa carte à l'ump
je peux vous faire une carte d'adhérent
si vous voulez un peu et je regarde pas
trop les guerres de l'info
alors votre idée avoue en fait c'était
que copé quittent la direction de l'ump
pendant la campagne et qu'il soit
remplacé par une personnalité
incontestable
le problème c'est que j'avais pensé à
michèle alliot marie
et ben moi j'aime bien michel a new
media comme enfin on peut pas dire
qu'elle soit incontestable appareils
pour croire de ben ali franchement non
bon allez vacances en tunisie elles sont
expliquées
tu n'as pas de casseroles et
couscoussière donc moi maintenant j'aime
bien michèle alliot marie se trouve que
c'est qu'elle s'est faite dans une
période où la politique était totalement
machiste on critiquait non-stop les
femmes qui n'étaient que des paires de
jambes à talons et elle au moins elle a
eu le courage de sa fille en détresse
alternèrent devient là par hasard enfin
dans les années 90 on sait bien ce que
c'était que être vraiment politique et
on se trouve que là elle a du courage
michèle alliot marie eba bon moi je suis
pour copé parce que ils sont pas près de
revenir au pouvoir à l'époque
la gauche
avec nos nombreux qu'on soir
[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes à la fois sur paris
première avec zemmour et naulleau et ça
balance à paris sur france 3 avec le
match des experts sur rtl avec berne et
puis à match paris match vous faites un
feuilleton littéraire ça fait beaucoup
quand même vous ayez pris quelqu'un pour
lire les livres à votre place toujours
pas pigé été viré de chez berne ah bon
c'est pour ça que ça remonter l'audience
sur tout non les jours pas jeu c'est
vrai que j'ai bien utilisé vos livres
toujours oui aussi vrai qu'on perd
beaucoup de temps donc je comprends ceux
qui ne le font pas et qui sont en
majorité à la télévision et à la radio
c'est un peu chronophage mais je trouve
qu'on donne un avis plus autorisées si
on a lu le livre avance et mâcon et en
plus vous publiez ça s'appelle pourquoi
tant de haine séché gosses évident c'est
une compilation de 20 ans chronique
comme je le disais dans le sommaire vous
aussi vous avez succombé au charme du
livre qui s'écrit avec une agrafeuse
rien il ya un peu de ça il faut
reconnaître oui mais j'ai fait beaucoup
d'efforts s'ils ont été très dures a
retrouvé ses textes sa famille
simplement d'un faux tout relié à il
faut boxer au vermont dans la marre de
se relire c'est une drôle c'est une
drôle de traverser la ville avait
beaucoup reproché aux autres de faire ça
vous le faites vous même maintenant non
je vais pas reprocher aux autres je
reproche pas de venin non baba non non
pas du tout ebe simplement il faut que
ça ait une cohérence voilà au bout de
vingt ans je ferai pas tous les ans mais
on a 20 ans et pas mal jaser dans 20 ans
mais voilà on se retrouvera dans quel
état je sais pas nous en tout cas moi je
serai toujours jamais vous ne changez
pas moi je risque d'avoir un peu ville
alors pour vendre ce livre j'ai fait
toutes les émissions il vous reste coi
le journal du hard non c'est à dire si
je vais pas fait c'est vrai mais faites
le nom mais le problème c'est que c'est
une attachée de presse dont je suis le
jouer elle est magnifique je comprends
qu'ils soient liés sans jouer c'est une
femme de l'est qui s'appelle slhoka et
je ne peux rien lui refuser je suis
marié avec une bulgare et mon attachée
de presse chez cosco vacoa c'est la
malédiction de l'est donc le journal du
hard mon avis est dans les tuyaux
alors vous rêvez toujours d'un prennent
culturelle sur france 2 n'ait pas
compris que c'est patrick sébastien qui
s'en charge
alors tout ça ne répond pas à la
question pourquoi tant de haine pourquoi
tant de haine parce que même si vous
l'écrivez e n sur la couverture on ne
pense à n va évidemment vous en prenez
toujours à ce pauvre beigbeder pour son
film à bernard henri lévy à christine
angot je suis pas tellement démenti par
les faits mais je suis le problème c'est
que je prends les livres un parent c'est
à dire si beigbeder fait un
chef-d'oeuvre je le dirai mais sans
prendre de gants je le dirais
franchement ce n'est pas arrivé je dois
dire que les probabilités s'amenuise à
mesure que les années passent mais je
suis aux aguets dès qu'il écrira une
bonne ligne je reviendrai vous en
parlerai dans le livre pour ceux qui ont
compris la peine de le lire il ya
vraiment 80% d'amour de la littérature à
chaque page on sait que c'est parce que
vous n'êtes pas écrivain non pas du tout
ça c'est à vous de clichés qui traînent
sur les critiques le en même temps il ya
beaucoup de critiques qui sont écrivains
et réciproquement et je crois que c'est
traîner avec moi par exemple je
collectionne les recueils de chroniques
c'est renaud matignon ah bah c'est
extraordinaire on n'influe matignon sur
moi il avait dit thierry ardisson vient
du néant et après deux heures de vie
d'yves y retourne c'est extraordinaire
c'est littéraire mais c'est bien le
maire presque parfait mais c'est bien je
trouve ça un peu naïve d'opposer la
critique à la littérature parce que le
sait c'est de la littérature dans les
deux cas bien entendu on passe
maintenant à l'actualité de la semaine
avec les vitres de blacko et c'est
rachida el azzouzi journaliste à
médiapart que nous retrouverons sur ce
plateau après le magnéto
depuis que la crise bat son plein c'est
le triomphe des produits locaux les
voitures les hypermarchés les billets
d'avions 'tout le monde' cassent les
prix mais puisque tout est low cost
pourquoi les patrons n'embauchent
seraient pas des ouvriers locaux
on peut tout acheter moins cher et sur
plaisir alors évidemment au départ les
français avaient dit non en votant
contre le traité européen en 2005 s'il
croyait avoir mis à la porte le plombier
polonais pts mais le voilà qui reviendra
fenêtres et attention il n'est pas tout
seul aujourd'hui plus de 300 mille
salariés venus des pays de l'est mais
aussi d'espagne et du portugal travail
en france à prix cassés
quoi six fois plus qu'il ya cinq ans
selon le parisien sur internet il suffit
de quelques clics pour trouver des
agences d'intérim spécialisées qui
propose des polonais pour pas cher sur
leur site elle met d'ailleurs en avant
leurs prestigieux clients français
l'avantagé pour l'employeur qu'en fait
c'est qu'il va payer ses charges en
pologne où elles sont moins importantes
qu'en france ça reste légal à condition
que les intérimaires étrangers soient
payés au smic et bénéficient des 35
heures or c'est rarement car une fille
surtout dans le secteur du bâtiment
qu'on constate le plus d'infractions
aujourd'hui pour construire le père de
flamanville pleurons du nucléaire
français l'état a choisi bouygues il vit
à embaucher des travailleurs polonais
par l'intermédiaire d'une agence
d'intérim irlandaise qui elle-même payer
ses charges sociales à chypre alors pour
sa défense oui explique que les jeunes
français ne se bousculent pas pour venir
bosser dans le bâtiment
cela dit on les comprend les jeunes
français c'est quand même dangereux le
bâtiment
ça représente 9% des salariés et 30 %
des accidents mortels alors c'est plus
prudent de laisser à d'autres
à
voilà c'était limite de blacko mise en
image de julien gracq bravo julien bravo
rachida bonsoir d'amis parmi nos alors
il avait réalisé pour mediapart
l'enquète sur les européens low cost des
chantiers français mais il faut d'abord
préciser que vous venez du puy-en-velay
vous êtes une ponote et vous avez
travaillé pour l'éveil de la haute loire
effectivement le quotidien du soir comme
elle elle son top les meufs la barbette
il n'y a pas que des zombies chez nous
y'a pas que les zombies là et c'est
surtout la première fois que sur un
plateau on est deux ponots et voilà la
prochaine fois on vient avec notre sac
de lentilles alors rachida il y aurait
en france trois cent trente mille
salariés low cost venus des pays de
l'est de l'europe du sud sont vendus
effectivement par des agences d'intérim
il suffit de regarder sur google ce café
blakowski alors ils sont vendus à la
restauration à l'agriculture et surtout
aux bâtiments et travaux publics alors
les cotisations sociales sont payés dans
le pays d'origine qui permet un peu
moins cher mais surtout au lieu d'être
payées au smic français ils sont payés
au smic de leur pays d'origine
exactement ils gagnent entre 500 et 1000
euros et cette estimation donc c'est
qu'une estimation 330000 parce que c'est
effectivement très difficile de les
frais cela plus parler
des entreprises évitent de déclarer
lors le détachement ce qui fait que
c'est très très difficile de les
comptabiliser alors une espèce de marché
noir légal même l'état les collectivités
locales les entreprises publics octroie
des marchés à des entreprises qui ont
recours eiffage vinci oui les grands
majors du btp sont tous se sont tous
engouffrés dans la brèche sont les
premiers à l'utiliser mais quand vous
leur dites après un carton alors dit ça
ils disent oui c'est vrai oui mais ils
disent on sous traite à l'étranger donc
ils renvoient la responsabilité aux
entreprises portugaises entrepreneurs
launay vraie reprise roumaine moi je les
ai vécus sur un méchant pied au puy en
velay et on a refusé et je pense que une
des première question qui est posée
enfin en tout cas c'est un thème majeur
c'est que quand on fait de la commande
publique il faut qu'on ait ce
raisonnement ouais tir de se dire quand
on fait un marché public est ce qu'on en
profite pour former des jeunes est-ce
qu'on s'assure que ce soit les
entreprises qui respectent un minimum
les règles qui le font et je crois que
là il ya vraiment un travail de
vigilance d'abord des élus mais laurent
regardez par exemple le carré de jaude à
clermont-ferrand
ça a été fait par des ouvriers locaux
payés à la tâche comme au bon vieux
temps à la tonne de ferraille et
certains pas payer des salariés
portugais n'était pas payé et je reviens
sur ce que disait monsieur wauquiez tout
le monde adopte une posture de fermeté
ou non je ne pense pas la fédération
française du bâtiment la principale
organisation patronale est vent debout
contre le dumping social et contre ce
type de pratique et telle est la
première toutes ces entreprises petites
ou grosses passe par ce type de de
marché tout le monde pleure tout le
monde est contre cette semaine encore le
ministre du travail michel sapin a dit
toutes ces situations de fraude
sont poursuivis jugés et condamnés mais
c'est faux c'est mentir il ya un
deuxième sujet un dernière c'est que au
fond quand on fait la course aux prix le
moins cher c'est ça qu'on récupère et
pour moi la question elle s'oppose
évidemment là dessus mais elle se pose
aussi sur ce qu'on achète dire que quand
on achète systématiquement les produits
les moins chers et que ces produits les
moins chers sont des produits qui sont
chinois la réalité c'est qu'on détruit
l'emploi chez nous et donc la démarche
c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous avez très
bien mis en avant c'est une question
plus fondamentale de la prost low cost
est ce que l'on veut acheter le moins
cher est acceptée de détruire de
l'emploi et avoir n'importe quoi ou
est-ce qu'on accepte de dire parfois il
vaut mieux payer un marché public 5% 10%
plus cher et en profiter les clauses
d'insertion et en profiter pour avoir
des entreprises locales moi mon marché
il m'a coûté plus cher vous avez eu
aussi des cueilleurs de champignons
bulgares et roumains dans les flandres
et du livradois forez qui sont venus à
ramasser des champignons pour faire des
fricassée à la maison est bien employé
par les foyers les informations c'est
que erdf fait appel à un prestataire de
services pour fournir des travailleurs
low cost les espagnols qui couplé qui
élaguent les arbres mais là encore ainsi
si on va à la racine du sujet moi c'est
ce qui m'intéresse avec la droite
sociale le problème c'est l'europe
d'hier qui au fond qu'est ce que ça
montre c'est qu'on peut pas avoir une
europe qui fonctionne avec des règles de
marché du travail et de fiscalité qui
sont différents pokémon ya une chose qui
m'échappe on met en place une europe
libérale dont cet homme des conséquences
que c'est un plus consultez ce que vient
de dire mme nolot la directive
bolkenstein date pas d'hier ce phénomène
il existe depuis des années il n'est pas
nouveau non bien sûr qu allez vous fait
vous avez été vous même ministre des
affaires aurait bien sûr il a été
secrétaire d'état à l'emploi qu'avez
vous fait pour lutter contre ce
phénomène cela va prendre hormis le cas
du puy-en-velay où vous avez par exemple
très précis la directive bolkenstein
telle qu'elle était initialement c'était
effectivement la possibilité de venir
avec les salaires de son fils le plus en
vue en pologne voilà maintenant la règle
européenne qui existent si on la fait
appliquer vous l'avez vous même dit
c'est qu'on est payés au salaire
français donc on est capable de le faire
mais ce que ce dont je suis convaincu
moi j'ai aucun problème avec le
libéralisme je suis pour un
protectionnisme européen donc j'ai aucun
problème là dessus je suis pas du tout
pour une europe libérale mais ce que je
pense c'est que au fond on voit bien
avec ces cas qu'on n'arrive pas à régler
que c'est le résultat d'une europe qui
allait trop loin vide et donc qu'il faut
recentrer et voilà c'est que vous êtes
vous engagé solennellement ce soir ne
jamais faire appel à des zombies
polonais au cuivre n'ont dit si vous
faites mais c'est le lot si vous faites
la promesse de ne pas faire appel à des
attachés de presse bulgare d'accord
enfin que touchent pas la bulgarie le
problème ce sont les contrôles parce
qu'évidemment il n'y a pas les moyens il
n'y a pas le temps et puis quand vous
choper des travailleurs locaux sur un
chantier vous êtes obligés de revenir
avec un traducteur assermenté donc le
temps que vous reveniez avec le
traducteur assermenté
les mecs se sont battus via des patrons
leur ont dit va te cacher quoi j en vois
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
effectivement
de direction du travail etc
c'est terrifiant ce qu'elle travaille
avec des moyens cro magnon elle le
disait le même marqué face à un système
opaque où les où les entrepreneurs tout
le monde sait faire on le sait
contourner des législations tout hyper
sophistiqué alors faut savoir qu'un
inspecteur du travail il est affecté à
un territoire une île à une unité de
territoire il n'en sort pas donc on va
dire ça peut être un territoire on prend
l'exemple que j'étais en au vert donc si
demain il a un sous traitant en midi
pyrénées par exemple il n'ya pas gré des
allées ensuite si ce sous traitant a
sous traité en pologne et n'a pas non
plus le droit de se déplacer ensuite
c'est pas des officiers de police
judiciaire du travail ils n'ont pas le
temps il travaille déjà sur l'hygiène et
la sécurité il déplace sur les accidents
du site en russie un truc rachida c'est
que la mission dure moins longtemps que
la procédure et quart le temps que la
procédure se met en place les mecs sont
déjà sur un autre chantier exact donc
c'est mort mais il faut aussi qu'on
sache faire le tri sur nos contrôles
c'est à dire que parfois on a du
harcèlement qui tombe pour fois parfois
pour des petites choses qui sont sans
importance et al'inverse on n'est pas
capable de mettre en place une lutte là
dessus alors comment ça se passe sur les
chantiers par exemple entre les ouvriers
locaux ce qui viennent de pologne
portugal bulgarie et puis les
travailleurs français comment ça se
passe alors là je vous renvoie un
ouvrage remarquable une enquête du
sociologue nicolas jounin qui s'est fait
lui même embauché en tant qu' en tant
qu'ouvrier sur les chantiers donc lui
c'était le petit blanc il raconte une
ségrégation
woinic kiki et qui était assez
terrifiante un racisme entre français et
étrangers mais aussi entre étrangers
eux-mêmes maintenant est ce que ces gens
là finalement ce sont pas les nouveaux
esclaves des esclaves modernes c'est la
question que pose effectivement les
syndicats notamment la cgt la cfdt ou
encore force ouvrière qui se déplace et
qui tente tant bien que mal de traquer
ces fraudeurs c'est essayer parce que
finalement qui est derrière ce sont des
entrepreneurs c'est la fédération
française du bâtiment c'est le patronat
voilà le mais quand on parle aux gens du
btp on leur dit quand même les employés
des esclaves ils m'attendaient les
français veulent pas le faire est ce que
c'est vrai ou pas
effectivement entre celui qui vous
explique qu'il fait ça parce que les
français ne veulent plus travailler ou
alors ils veulent tous est payé 25 euros
delà entre celui qui vous dit ah non
mais je fais çà mau faiblesse que c'est
faux ça mais c'est faux parce que tout
le monde pourquoi on sous traite on sous
traite par un souci de moindres coûts
non mais pour dire les choses crûment
gars la traite des blanches avec les
réseaux de prostitution et la traite des
blancs avec les ouvriers du bâtiment ça
revient à peu près au même quand il ya
une réalité qu'un tout petit peu moins
dénoncé que l'autre mais c'est
inadmissible quand ça va pas vous plaire
mais pourquoi on fait ça parce que la
réalité c'est qu'en france on a accumulé
énormément de charges sociales et que
donc la différence entre ce qu'on a avec
le salaire chargé et le salaire qu'on
trouvait qu'on propose avec une
entreprise polonaise ou portugaise est
trop folle dont l'importance et c'est là
où je comprends pas ce que font les
socialistes plutôt que de financer notre
protection sociale avec les charges sur
les travailleurs de la financer en
faisant payer les produits importés par
le biais de la tva et quand on voit les
socialistes qui disent banon on va
traiter tout ça dans un an et demi bah
désolé quand on vous entend se dit faut
le faire maintenant ce qu'on est en
train de raconter ce soir peut amener le
gouvernement socialiste à réfléchir plus
avant à la flexibilité du temps de
travail ou surtout faire plus vite bah
oui parce que on comprend bien que quand
vous avez d'un côté des salaires ou sur
lesquels on fait peser tout notre
protection sociale en financement et de
l'autre côté des salaires qui coûte
beaucoup moins cher mais la réalité
c'est qu'on se retrouve avec ce genre de
situation si on veut rester à gauche la
briser ce tabou eric la gauche au
pouvoir elle est libérale donc c'est pas
elle qui va briser
tabou non non c'est qu'est ce que ça
veut dire on est libéral on n'est pas
une question d'idéologie
un moment à nous de changer de logiciel
mais l'idée ce sont les mêmes
centre-droit centre gris erilia il n'y a
aucune idéologie dans le fait de dire
que l'on fait financer notre protection
sociale à 100% par celui qui travaille
aucune juste une question de bon sens de
se dire il faut que les produits
importés chinois et indiens on les fasse
payer pour notre financement de la
protection sociale le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait en
allemagne il ya des travailleurs qui
sont beaucoup beaucoup moins bien payés
qu'en france
mais mary pierce est resté un an mais
non parce que qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
les allemands ils ont diminué les
charges ça veut dire qu'ils s'en sortent
avec des salaires qui en moyenne sont
plus élevé en allemagne qu'en france
mais qui coûte en moyenne moins cher aux
entreprises parce qu'ils ont supprimé
les charges et donc ça montre bien qu'on
paye les charges en allemagne mais ils
ont diminué leur financement de charge
ils ont recréé de la valeur ils ont mis
des taxes notamment taxe écologique sur
les produits importés et du coup ils
arrivent à s'en sortir beaucoup mieux et
enfin du coup l'allemagne va bien mais
les allemands pas si bien quoi est ce
que c'est ça le modèle afin désolé mais
si on vend d'ailleurs en allemagne c'est
pas c'est pas quand même une sinécure et
un examen mais ça c'est toujours
l'argument qu'on arrive à dire là parce
qu'il va alors ils vont bien sûr le taux
de chômage ils ont des salaires qui sont
plus élevés mais comme par hasard les
allemands il ya des fausses mika ya en
effet des gens qui sont payés le traité
mais l'europe et sa chance existe et
l'europe j'en suis convaincu et
finalement ce sujet le montre c'est que
ça ne peut pas marcher avec des pays
aussi différents coins et malgré tout
quand vous avez un tel écart entre la
france et la pologne va c'est pas
possible de trouver le point d'équilibré
donc il faut revenir à quelques pas de
l'europe concentré oui où on est capable
par contre de faire l'harmonisation des
salaires l'harmonisation des impôts et
de régler ce type de difficultés à la
maintenant
quelques janvier d'un concurrent débat
bref c'est la merde
il peut y avoir des jumeaux ris low cost
j'étais hauteur pour la télé trouve ça
un peu aussi payé le connaissent pas les
humoristes de l'est qui vous remplace
ronde
c'est ça qu'est ce que ça va être
difficile c'est très difficile en tous
les cas qu'il ya de mercy de braga ciel
vous merci à la tienne aujourd'hui
youtube
[Applaudissements]
parce que ce soir ce soir c'est
l'anniversaire de son papa avancerait
va dire ça va pas voilà c'était de
bons changements prennent appui avec
jean louis gasc barbe rouge et la
gravité du salut l'after ce soit mon
renault se bat pour la reconnaissance
des droits des avantages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh mon choix était un grand moment là
nous sommes toujours encore banni de la
beauté
rachida dati
et nous accueillons notre habileté du
samedi 20 ce soir or en rayon bonsoir
maintenant j'ai un coeur gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
alors le grand choc de la semaine
évidemment la conférence de presse de
rené coty
prévue pour durer une heure et demie ça
a débordé d'une demi heure c'est un
signe c'est comme au foot quand on sait
pas marquer dans le temps réglementaire
ont dans les prolongations
alors rien que son introduction c'est a
duré 45 minutes il vous apprennent quoi
à l'ena
après j'ai compris pourquoi ça a duré si
longtemps chirurgie une introduction ça
s'appelle une anesthésie et là on a eu
droit à la péridurale de l'esprit cochon
malin hollande malin il a pris son temps
pour bien faire allumer dans le crâne
des journalistes le petit clignotant bon
il est où le buffet ya les coupes à
champagne
la grande interrogation c'est évidemment
est-ce qu'il va réussir sa conférence de
presse ils sont courants les journaleux
que c'est lui qui a fixé la date et
qu'il a eu six mois pour s'y préparer je
sais pas quoi je rappelais que c'est un
énarque quand même la formation d'un
énarque j'ai vu ça coûte 160 8000 euros
par an ouais enfin si à ce tarif là tu
arrives à te faire déstabiliser par une
question denisot delahousse et qui est
un problème
alors l'opposition qui est très déçus
qui est très déçue évidemment vous vous
attendiez à quoi
qu'il dise quoi pour vous faire plaisir
moi président enfin je le crois
ou du moins on me le dit mais je n'en
suis pas sûr alors je n'en ai ni les
capacités ni le talent ni le charisme
mais je me dois d'être dans
l'affaissement
parce qu'un président de la république
c'est aussi un appel heures sa relaxe
ans et c'est un homéopathe de la vie
publique un ostéopathe de la cohésion
sociale
une herboriste de l'industrie française
oui je le dis
parce que
oui
je me dois
pour persévérer dans la droite ligne de
ma nullité transcendantale
moi j'aimerais annoncer
que l'année prochaine nous allons sortir
du nucléaire mais aussi de l'hydraulique
de l'éolien du pétrole du compost et
même du solaire
moi je n'oublie pas mes engagements
je le dois aux français oui au droit de
vote aux étrangers mais par souci d'
équilibre car il faut apaiser et je suis
un herboriste
je veux le supprimer au français comme
je veut interdire le mariage
hétérosexuel sauf entre cousins frères
et les personnes qui ont leurs quarante
annuités de cotisation
j'annonce aussi un nouveau paquet fiscal
qui portera la tv à 80 % la cg à 90 sur
l'impôt sur le revenu à 145 alors tout
ça je je en gros 1 en gros je suis bien
sûr je pars pas des velléités de
d'imitateur encore que canteloup doit
trembler mais avec cet humour
typiquement hollandais tu vois moi je
vois les sondages mais un sondage ne
fait pas le printemps
encore moins les galeries lafayette ou
la samaritaine
[Applaudissements]
et les journalistes tellement shooter
qui lui ont trouvé des accents
churchilliens
ah bon
il a dit quoi qu'il fallait stocker du
riz et de la farine en vue des futures
bombardement de l'année remarque que va
sortir les soldats d'afghanistan les
concentrer sur la rive gauche du rhin si
seulement seulement non parce que ça
c'est moi c'est un serment et commence à
me pomper les cheveux coiffés encore ce
qu'on devrait faire ce qu'on devrait pas
faire quoi c'est bon quoi nous on est là
comme des cons aplati devant cette
fascination pour l'industrie allemandes
savent à quoi ça va quoi quand même pas
recevoir des leçons de ces ploucs en
birkenstock qui sont fait défoncer par
des chars de fabrication soviétique
alors évidemment en face pour la droite
qui couine ouais ouais mais si hollande
a vu le courage de se redresse savent à
quoi il a fallu six mois hollande pour
rétablir la tva quand sarko a mis dix
ans à piger que ça serait peut-être une
idée de supprimer les 35 heures
alors sarko il fait penser à un
parkinsonien épileptique l'illusion de
l'énergie dans la certitude du surplace
bref alors quelqu'un y est allé de son
couplet forcément je pense tout le monde
l'avait appelée selon françois bayrou
hollande a été à la hauteur de la
fonction qu'est ce qui dit koné by
l'entendre parler de la fonction
présidentielle on dirait un puceau qui a
pondu une thèse sur le point g
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment dans ce contexte c'est
normal que des artistes émergent
[Musique]
voilà on a trouvé le bob dylan de droite
vous pussy riot monégasque s'il habite à
monaco le tips à monaco grand repaire de
poètes cela la butte montmartre de la
méditerranée quand tu penses le gamin il
a 16 ans et 16 ans à 16 ans son problème
c'est le taux d'imposition
quoi parler de l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur un français a gagné au loto on
connaîtra pas son nom c'est pas con il
veut rester discret c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde exemple lagardère arnaud
la télé belge a fait un reportage sur
lui quand tu le vois dilapidé son pognon
on te dit que 75 % taux d'imposition
c'est un cadeau
je peux dire qu'à côté de lagardère
bernard tapie c'est mario monti
en revanche le type il a du flair quoi
se trouvait une cagole en belgique faut
y aller
ce cas le seul français qui vont en
belgique pour s'appauvrir autant bernard
arnault il s'exile pour payer moins
d'impôts lui c'est pour épouser une
belge pour diminuer ses bénéfices quoi
c'est bon la fille pas très futé pour
une croqueuse de diamants prendre un mec
qui n'a que cinquante ans
autant de patience ça s'appelle de
l'amour
ou alors arnauts et qui doit les
rassurer lui way est inquiète page et
quatre-vingt dix ans mais j'ai toujours
fait moins que mon âge
parlons d'amour ça fait bizarre de vous
voir
sans humour ça que c'est pas eric
naulleau sans humour c'est un peu comme
ces moules sont dieudonné on gagne en
compassion ce qu'on perd en rire
parlant de décès médiatique
l'international nous fournit
régulièrement son lot de macchabées
ouverture de la tombe d'arafat c'est
quelle folie ne jamais décongeler de la
viande halal
après gigot de cette heure-là rafat de
deux enfants
dans tout ça pour voir s'il n'a pas été
farci au plutonium serait que l'
avantage s'ils en trouvent ce qu'ils
pourront toujours envoyer la dépouille
en iran pour qu'ils enrichissent leurs
bombes
je propose des choses voilà c'est ça
faut essayer tous loués est d'ailleurs
un propos il ya une jolie campagne
d'affichage collectif de lutte contre
l'islamophobie qui a été refusé par la
ratp oui s'ils sont très mal pris fin il
fallait casser les codes rendre se
rendre sympathique quoi toi au fond ce
que les gens reprochent un peu aux
musulmans c'est de pas avoir assez
d'autodérision c'est ça moi j'avais une
idée de campagne quoi une belle campagne
avec un mouton un barbu dans une
baignoire et le slogan entre nous c'est
une histoire de goût
[Applaudissements]
ouais ça sent la fatwa quoi
bien sûr il faut peut-être terminée par
quelque chose d'un peu jauni à cette
mort jolie je ne sais pas marionnettiste
accusé de pédophilie
les gens trouvent ça étonnant
franchement quand un type qui fait rire
des gosses en ayant un bras coincé dans
le cul d'un ours en peluche bon
[Applaudissements]
le glauque dans toute sa splendeur alors
évidemment et ce cas une bonne nouvelle
cette semaine
il ya eu la journée de la gentillesse
je sais pas moi je comprends pas trop
journée de la gentillesse je pensais
qu'on avait déjà eu c'est la journée de
la femme c'est là on a donné un jour
mais alors pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
et puis
where pouvez suivre l'actu de l'émission
sur twitter via le compte les terriens
et le hashtag slt on passe maintenant à
notre invité du samedi 20 au
[Musique]
renom re bonsoir sera vous êtes né le
1er février 1981 à palaiseau père
ingénieur chez thales mère femme au
foyer
à l'école vous êtes une élève doué mais
bavarde ya quinze jours la maîtresse
vous mets du scotch sur la bouche quand
même oui c'était pour la sieste
alors à l'adolescence est une jeune
fille comme toutes les autres
complètement hétéro en tous les cas vous
avez des amourettes avec des garçons il
vous est même choqué quand à l'âge de 16
ans vous tombez sur un reportage
consacré à des familles homoparentales
vous dites à votre mère c'est n'importe
quoi et votre mère vous dit elles font
ce qu'elles veulent en quoi ça te
regarde
c'est vraiment histoire oui
alors en décembre 2002 après le bac et
un bts de comptabilité vous entrez dans
un cabinet d'expertise-comptable à paris
et là il ya la fille du patron
alors cette fille du patron elle fait
partie du staff évidemment delà de la
boîte mais les employés là la
fréquentent pas trop un nom à ne pas
approcher way est elle-même elle n'avait
pas trop le droit de parler avec les
autres n'ont effectivement son père lui
avait interdit de parler en dehors du
minimum des travaux à la alors vous vous
avez besoin d'un vous débarquez
maintenant et elle vous explique votre
votre job en fait alors c'est le début
d'une histoire d'amour vous dites
c'était beaucoup plus fort qu avec une
amie mais qui attirait lunettes oui
voilà alors à l'été 2003 vous partez en
vacances séparément et là vous découvrez
que vous ne pouvez pas être très loin
l'une de l'autre et vous dites on a
passé notre était au téléphone oui
c'est là que la relation c'est encore
plus développés puisque on a parlé
données dépendantes l'une de l'autre
voilà mon retour de vacances vous
installer ensemble et quelques mois plus
tard votre relation devient officiel
gens parler à vos parents ils ont réagi
comment vos parents ce qui les dérange
le plus c'est que c'était un fils du
patron ouais pas la fille en fait alors
question enfants au début on vous dit on
en aura jamais
jusqu'au jour où clément c'est son nom
changeait évidemment rentrer en parlant
d'insémination artificielle avec donneur
ça commence à vous souhaiter ça commence
à trotter à dire que c'est possible en
fait ouais
plus accessible
à vous renseigner sur internet parce que
dans ces cas là on va sur les forums
d'internet est en fait voilà vous poser
des questions parce que vous avez peur
de traumatiser l'enfant vous vous dites
est ce qu'on a le droit d'imposer à un
enfant d'avoir deux mamans et papas
c'est ce et c'est de lui imposer nos
choix nous ce sera son choix lui à notre
choix nous voilà et ben c'est lourd de
conséquences il faut y réfléchir alors
finalement vous décidé à sauter le pas
et vous demander laquelle des deux sera
la première à enfanter alors vous
choisissez clémence en fait parce que
les plus âgés que vous ayez 30 ans il
venait 26 et ça elle se dit faut faire
un enfant avant il ya une date limite
quoi alors belgique à une date limite
way 35 ans pour les étrangers fait ça à
bruxelles à la clinique edith cavell est
en fait c'est pas grand chose un
bouddhiste est commun oui enfin frottis
quoi oui exactement elles sont fait
toute une montagne
mais sait on est frappé par la
simplicité du geste ouais ça coûte pas
très cher
sa peau très cher c'est réussi du
premier coup ouais ouais mais vous ça a
marché du monde
250 euros plus le train à la surprise la
grosse surprise c'est qu'à la première
échographie vous découvrez avec clémence
qu'elle est enceinte de jumeaux
ça pose deux problèmes d'abord
financièrement c'est plus cher d'élever
deux enfants d'un seul et puis vous vous
dites si on a déjà deux du premier coup
moi je pourrai jamais porté le mien
la première réaction oui effectivement
c'est celle ci quoi c'est triste enfin
vous êtes heureuse quand même ah oui
c'est dans l'espace de 30 secondes pour
réfléchir à tout ça et là
tout de suite à l'échographie donc on
voit les les deux et la gynéco passe
tout de suite sur le
le son on entend les coeurs battre et
voilà quoi vous fait quand on aspire à
rien on est juste content
alors pendant la grossesse clémence est
obligé de rester au lit toute la journée
ce cas des nausées avait pas mais pas
très bien vie pas très bien sa grossesse
et vous vous tapez tout le travail
d'abord
la cuisine le ménage enfin bon vraiment
brillé je l'avais je l'avais carrément
interdit de faire quoi que ce soit
c'était les enfants avant tout est là
après moi j'assure l'intendance derrière
alors les jumeaux un garçon et une fille
inès le 1er octobre 2007
après le congé maternité quand lémance
reprend le travail vous devenez mère au
foyer oui je prends un projet parental
d'éducation par la caf c'est tout à fait
légal moi et c'est là que vous décidez
toutes les deux de partager cette
expérience
vous rencontrez un couple de lesbiennes
qui veut avoir des enfants et vous
devenez proche de ce couple mais en fait
on les reprend un peu sous notre couple
quoi parce que nous on a déjà fait tout
le parcours elle assure son au début
d'avoir décidé d'avoir un enfant donc on
donne des conseils
on les guide dans leurs choix en fait si
si vraiment c'est bien réfléchi
alors vous donner à ses proches de ce
couple oui vous voyez assez
régulièrement
jusqu'au jour où en septembre 2008 l'une
d'entre elles vous appelle elle s'est
séparé de sa compagne sont discutés elle
sait pas où aller et là bas vous lui
proposer de venir dormir chez vous oui
bonne pâte tu annules par valeria une
chambre de libre vient les deux chambres
devront presse
catastrophe oui erreur
fatale
quelques jours plus tard votre compagne
clémence
et la nouvelle venue couchent ensemble
elle vous dit je ne t'aime plus c'est
elle que j'aime quoi trois ans les îles
en plus très nette après
bon on encaisse ouais on encaisse on
essaie de réfléchir
comment on peut vous voulez mais
toujours ah oui moi j'aime aucun doute
aucun des enfants pour approcher en plus
oui
alors le jour où vous demanderez à
clémence de choisir entre cette fille et
vous
elle partira avec les enfants
et la fille sont toujours ensemble oui
or là aurore vous tentez de vous
suicider
heureusement clémence revient dans
l'appartement découvre votre corps
inanimés elle appelle le samu vous êtes
sauvés mais in extremis quoi c'était
d'après d'après les médecins qui me
penche un jour
vous réveillez cinq jours plus tard
service réanimation
et vous appelez clémence votre ex oui
pour lui dire que que voilà je n'ai
j'allais bien etc
pour la rassurer dans un premier temps
ouais et oui pour avoir des nouvelles
des enfants s'ils n'étaient pas trop
choquer elle répond pas
senti de l'hôpital vous lui demander de
revoir les enfants et elle vous dit hors
de question
alors là vous êtes sous anxiolytiques
vous pensez qu'elle changera d'avis
qu'on vous irait mieux oui bon le nom va
passer moi je vais me refaire une santé
et cetera mais elle ne changera pas
d'avis jamais
le justifier comment faire
c'est son caractère quand c'est fini
c'est fini il faut couper tous les ponts
est arrêté ouais m'enfin on peut être
comme ça mais quand il ya des enfants
peut pas être comme ça
et avait il y avait quelqu'un d'autre
pour me remplacer donc voilà j'étais
trop je pense alors il faudra trois ans
de procédure pour que vous soyez
autoriser à revoir les jumeaux un
week-end par mois
aucun contact entre éduquer les enfants
du mal à comprendre ça oui c'est un peu
ça un peu abstrait pour eux c'est ce
qu'ils me disent toutefois pas souvent
pourquoi donc mon gsm leur expliquer que
et un juge qui a décidé
que ce serait comme ça que j'essaie de
leur faire comprendre avec des mots
simples à comprendre ils sont cinq ans
donc ouais
alors le pire c'est qu'avec la loi qui
se prépare sur l'homoparentalité
la nouvelle compagne de votre ancienne
compagne clémence pourrait adopter les
jumeaux si la loi passe tel quel et dit
aux médias oui ce qu'elle pourrait
adopter vos enfants alors que vous
n'avez aucun droit à part le jugement
que j'ai eus obtenu ouais j'ai rien
c'est la première fois qu'un jugement
comme ça est rendue non oui je veux dire
quand même que l'état reconnaît
l'homoparentalité partir du moment où on
dit vous avez droit de voir les enfants
que tous les mois c'est qu'on reconnaît
vous êtes deux maman de deux enfants il
reconnaît le le lien lien affectif donc
là il ya un vide juridique évident vous
êtes ici pour
dénoncer cette situation bah oui parce
que parce que je ne peux pas faire
réviser mon jugement oui vous vous dites
si j'attaque le jugement je risque de
tout perdre voilà si si je demande à
avoir un peu plus je tombe sur un autre
juge qui n'est pas forcément pour bien
sûr l art là pour le coup vous risquez
pu les voir du tout voilà voilà faut que
je me contente de ce que j'ai et je
prends chaque minute de ce que j'ai si
vous avez quelque chose à lui dire ce
soir à clémence lui diriez quoi
je dirais d'être
peut-être tout l'aimanté de penser aux
enfants ouais et d'écouter les demandes
des enfants finalement c'est comme un
divorce classique oui sauf qu'on n'a pas
de droit voilà
c'est à cette différence alors c'est
quoi alors invoqué bon la loi
visiblement qui veut tout régenter
n'apportera aucune réponse est donc
essayons d'apporter des réponses à ce
qu'est un endroit parfaitement légitime
d'avoir un cadre qui protège votre vie
et donne quelque chose qu'il abrite mais
est ce que pour faire ça il faut aboutir
à ce qu'on nous propose c'est à dire le
chamboulement total et de la vision du
mariage et de la filiation et qui en
plus n'apportera aucune réponse à des
sujets de vie quotidienne est avec moi
je suis pas un grand fanatique du
mariage homosexuel mais moi ce que
j'entends dans votre histoire c'est
qu'en fait y'a pas de différences selon
que le couple sur composé d'un homme ou
d'une femme où deux femmes et je vois
pas ce qu'on peut opposer à cette
revendication d'égalité c'est les mêmes
choses des enfants qui sont partagés
entre les deux maires au lieu de l'être
entre un père et une mère donc je trouve
que ce serait même si on peut lui
opposer quelques arguments je pense que
ce serait une bonne chose de mettre tout
le monde à égalité parce qu'on voit que
indépendamment de la théorie dans la
pratique en fait ce sont les mêmes
situations les mêmes sentiments et
malheureusement les mêmes drames bien
merci de votre témoignage sera voilà
c'est tout à l'intérieur votre retour du
samedi avec kyan khojandi pour
l'intégrale de break en tout les jours
est et coffret collector jean wauthier
d'épicés de l'artois même puy-en-velay
merci eric naulleau beaucoup
jega ceviche sur paris première rachida
dati merci merci médiapart et or en
droit nous merci merci à tous ceux qui
m'ont rêver à faire cette émission je
vous laisse avec made in holland rendez
vous ici la joindre rochelle et qui
s'ils gagnent sur canalplus.fr avec en
bonus le peuple evans lévy toute l'agglo
l'édito des gréements et marcheurs de la
fnath gecas en brousse salut les
terriens
oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu